[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم الجيش الاسرائيلي يؤكد
اعتراض 25 صاروخا اطلقت من لبنان ويقول ان
اطلاقها من لبنان حدث خطير محملا الحكومه
اللبنانيه مسؤوليه اطلاقها من داخل
اراضيها الجيش اللبناني يعلن العثور على
منصات صواريخ وصواريخ معده للاطلاق ويؤكد
العمل على تفكيكها في الاثناء دعت بيروت
المجتمع الدولي للضغط على اسرائيل لوقف
التصعيد بعد ليله شهدت مواجهات عقب اقتحام
الاقصى والاعتداء على المصلين والمعتكفين
قوه الاحتلال تفرض قيودا على دخول المصلين
الفلسطينيين المسجد الاقصى ونحو 200
مستوطن يقتحمونه وسط حراسه مشدده من
الشرطه الاسرائيليه والامم المتحده تحث
جميع الاطراف على تجنب اي اجراء احادي
يمكن ان يؤدي الى زياده تصعيد الوضع اتفاق
سعودي ايراني بواسطه صينيه على تفعيل
اتفاقيه التعاون الامني واعاده فتح
السفارتي البلدين خلال فتره شهرين المتفق
عليها وبجين تقول انها تدعم دول الشرق
الاوسط في الحفاظ على استقلالها
الاستراتيجي والتخلص مما وصفته بالتدخل
الخارجي المكتب التنفيذي للكونفدراليه
الافريقيه لكره القدم يصادق بالاجماع على
دعم ترشيح المغرب لاستضافه كاس العالم
لكره القدم عام 2030 الى جانب اسبانيا
والبرتغال في ملفهم الثلاثي المشترك
الى اللقاء